alright I'm not gonna lie I have missed
this outfit
[Applause]
[Music]
all right folks Doctor Who series 12 it
has its first trailer it had some
casting announcements for guest stars go
out and we have an airdate for the
series got a bit of stuff to talk about
if you have not already watched the new
trailer for series 12 please do so I'll
link below for that because I'm not this
is not a breakdown this is not point
four point there are a couple things
I'll highlight and dwell on but you need
to just go watch for yourself if you
haven't already so my thoughts on this
trailer there's a number of things that
I really liked first of all it's looking
good that's not surprising
I thought series 11 looked really good
from a visual standpoint also there are
some very nice moments that I like
little touches that I think are quite
cool around character I also kind of
like the rock music that's going on with
it I'm liking the bits of Jodie
Whittaker that we get and in her
performance of this like aspect my
favorite moment it came early I kind of
wish it had come in a little bit later
but I really loved her both the line and
her delivery of this is not where I
expected to be but I can work with this
like that that was the feel of the
doctor that I was really starting to
enjoy by the time series 11 ended and I
got a little bit of it in resolution as
well so now that I finally feel like I
got I get her that is what I want to see
out of her and I was very happy to see
it in this trailer we don't get a ton on
the Companions they're just kind of
their reiteration of family yes we've
hammered that home very well but no cool
they're there they're back fine as far
as the guest stars that we confirmed one
of those is Stephen Fry who I enjoyed
quite a bit and he has a great sense of
gravitas in the one line that he gets in
this trailer like that there's a Lenny
Henry who I know nothing about so I have
absolutely no opinion about his
involvement there are a couple of things
that are throwing me off
a little bit and other things that are
not concerning even in and of themselves
but maybe concerning as far as what they
might indicate and I'm not necessarily
talking narrative or plot stuff I'm not
gonna do a ton of speculation that's not
really how my brain works but I am gonna
start to touch on a few things here if
there was one moment that I actively
disliked in and of itself it was the
doctor on a motorcycle now I have never
really cared for action II scenes in the
Doctor Who especially when they involve
the doctor themself like I've just never
really cared for it and they've done it
with most of them they did it with
Tennant they had some motorcycle stuff
go on with Smith you know that when that
sort of thing happens they just that's
not that's not why I love the doctor
that's not why the doctor is one of my
favorite characters and favorite heroes
because of action scenes the doctor an
action scene always feels weird to me
and well I understand like it's just a
chase that a chase is a kind of action
scene so in my mind the most the doctor
should be doing is running from and I
suppose this could be somebody that but
this becomes a high-speed chase as
opposed to just get out of the way which
is standard operating procedure so
that's about the one thing that I can
look at and go that I don't like there's
other stuff that I saw that is not a
prominent of itself and that will
ultimately be execution dependent which
all of this is going to be obviously but
there were a few things here so we get
some little glimpses of some things that
we already knew we're returning plus
some glimpses of other stuff that hadn't
heard about and may not connect but I'd
be surprised if it didn't so like we got
a glimpse of the and we also heard the
Judoon awesome I'm kind of happy that
they're gonna be back I'll be very
curious to see how they get used I doubt
that the to connect in terms of hearing
the Judoon dialogue and the commands
going what but that was a that was a
cool edit for the sake of a trailer dig
that we get Cybermen and I have mixed
feelings about that
kinda come back to that a little bit
later there was a neat image of like
something coming through the door of the
TARDIS like looking like is kind of
phasing through it was hard to make out
those largely just a silhouette it
looked cyber managed to me it kind of
had the head outline for it but it was
hard to make out that could be something
else but that looked like a Cyberman
coming through the door to my eye
there also was this really quick glimpse
of honestly what looked a lot like the
racnoss Queen from runaway bride now I'm
on the record as not being a very big
fan of the racnoss at all but a lot of
that came down to the camp eNOS of the
performance so that may not be in play
this time and as far as why I think it
looks similar is very similar does that
it's a very quick look it's only the
head but it's not just that the makeup
and the general design of the eyes and
the teeth looks similar it's also in the
performance because doing that kind of
thing that the racnoss was doing so I'm
feel like that's their eye my suspicion
of this about the one bit applause
speculation I'll make it may not be a
rack and a strictly speaking it might be
some kind of offshoot or related species
because we do see what looks like a
giant scorpion which makes me slightly
nervous but not because it's a bad thing
and I never self but be kinda but
because it immediately rang a bell of
arachnids in the UK which was the
episode I liked the least in series 11
but you know that's just ringing the
bell something I don't like I had no
reason to believe that they're related
and also the giant spiders are sending
of themselves were not the problem with
that episode so that's baggage I need to
move on from but I do wonder if this
rack no screen instead of being a queen
of spiders is like a scorpion variant of
the racnoss that's sort of my one
thought as far as that goes
if only because it would feel like way
too many insect or spider and I know
spiders and insects are different things
but like way way too many different
creepy crawly kind of things going on in
a series that I believe is only 10
episodes so it would be weird to me if
those were two separate things both
banking on that kind of imagery I would
expect them to be in the same house Odin
so backing up and well no not quite yet
because I was gonna start talking about
why the Cyberman thing has me a little
mean but there's other factors that play
into that so we got a premiere date for
the new season series 12 the first
episode is going to air on New Year's
Day now it needs to be stressed this is
not a special we had a New Year special
last year with most are not last year
technically the beginning of this year
with resolution now what this is going
to be is it is going to be the start
actually I believe it has been confirmed
the first part of a two-part episode and
then the series continues after that I
have not I don't know if it's been
confirmed one way or the other I could
not find if they have confirmed that
subsequent episodes will also air on
Wednesdays because that would be a week
after the initial one airs or if only
the premiere is on a Wednesday and then
it's gonna slide into the Sunday slot
that it had before I couldn't find
confirmation on that if somebody else
has found it you know link it below I'll
pin it in the comments but yeah I
couldn't find that either way it doesn't
really impact me other than trying to
figure out my shooting schedule going
into 2020 but yeah so the lack of a
special in and of itself not the end of
the world to me I I kind of like that
the specials exist even though I don't
especially like the Christmas specials
in particular most of them just really
didn't do much for me but I kind of
always liked that there was a special
in-between series there was something to
keep you know tide us over sort of a fun
holiday tradition and it now feels like
that's completely gone and that does
bummed me out a little bit I won't lie
but I'm not heavily invested in that as
a concept as an idea so here's where I'm
nervous and why I brought up the
Cybermen in relation to that series 11
which I have very mixed feelings about
on it and if you're curious about what
those are if you don't know where you
don't remember it did a whole video on
it but a lot of the big ideas
of that of that series were things that
I had wanted the show to do all
standalone episodes no overarching story
connected by some mystery element that
kept getting said over and over we
didn't find out what it was till a
finale that entire structure to the
series overall was gone a year without
returning villains there were none in
series 11 we had them in the special but
that is kind of detached and
disconnected from that these were all
fairly bold alterations and while I feel
that series 11 was very mixed I don't
think any of those decisions were the
cause of any of the issues at least that
I personally had about the series so it
makes me nervous going into series 12
that we have way more returning villains
we're getting a two-parter as an opener
and there were little things in the
trailer that really felt like they were
hinting at a larger story like the idea
that someone is hunting the doctor that
doesn't feel like a one episode story
that feels like something you stretch
over a season arc now that last one is
the most tenuous that is literally just
me getting a vibe but here's why all
that makes me nervous
regardless of how the actual execution
of it is and all this may turn out to be
for the best I can't help but get
nervous around the optics
of all of so many elements that series
11 made the decision to no we're gonna
build something without those elements
at least to start is bringing nearly all
of them back in the very next series
that has the look and feel of of going
well we completely screwed that up bring
back everything we left behind and again
I'm not a huge fan of series 11 but
those things weren't my issue with
series 11 and if they're bringing and
again they may not be bringing those
things back to try and quote-unquote fix
things they may be bringing them back to
more legitimate reasons but the fact
that they're all coming back right away
it can't help but look like a very
reactive move a very reactionary move of
going okay so maybe you know we could
have done better so let's let's just
bring everything back
and that if that is the attitude which
again I don't know but if it is that's
fixing the wrong problems so I and this
is not me saying that I wouldn't have
wanted those things reintroduced at any
point that's not me saying I never
wanted to see a two-parter again that's
not me saying I never wanted to see
characters like Cybermen again but again
all flooding back the very next series
yeah that that the optics of that make
me nervous and I know some people are
gonna get very declarative about what
that means
I'm not cuz we don't know but I will
grant it has it can have the look of
behind the scene teams kind of kind of
shrugging and scrambling to a certain
extent so like the return of the Judoon
or even the racnoss like I'm totally
down with because if they're gonna start
bringing back recurring villains I would
like them to bring back the ones that
haven't been run into the ground if they
wanted to go back to classic Doctor Who
I've been calling for the return of
Omega for friggin ever but there are
plenty of others or even some that the
new series has dropped references to
like the draconians bring them back but
instead you and the special we got
Daleks and then we're right back to
Cybermen again the second most-used
recurring villain it just again my final
judgment will hinge on what the story
ends up being what the execution is but
just telling me oh look at all this
stuff we brought back makes me go you're
trying too hard to please me
and it's I'm not gonna say it's not
enough but it's not
endearing it makes me doubt the strength
of your conviction in what you're doing
and I really really hope that it is just
one of those cases where they are making
you know a creative decision we have a
really good story to do with the
Cybermen or we definitely have a story
that needs two parts and those are the
reasons behind bringing these things
back I hope that is the case deeply but
I would be
of sticking my head in the sand if I
didn't acknowledge the fact that the
optics of this don't point in a
direction I'd love but again they only
point in that direction it's not
definitive there's a dog hacking up on
the floor right now yeah I'm leaving
that in because I'm too lazy to edit but
you know whatever the motivation behind
this is I that's just how my brain works
and that's not me going I hope series 12
fails now I don't I wanted to be good I
wanted to be great this is still my
favorite show I want it to be good I
will always want it to be good but I've
also got a kind of brain that
immediately zeroes in on the things that
might point to a problem that's how my
head functions I can't help it so I
really hope I haven't brought people
down with my thoughts on this because
overall I think it was a pretty good
trailer and like so many things the
things that I'm seeing that are making
me go and I feel like might only be
exclusive to me in my head and the way
my frigging brain works so my apologies
for dumping that on all of you but you
want all my thoughts those are my
thoughts so series 12 trailer have you
seen it what do you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it there's other stuff to do
as well you can support me on patreon
and there's all the other buttons as
well links etc etc merch click on stuff
it'll take you places or don't you don't
have to because at the end of the day
you're the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
don't forget to click below and
subscribe to the official council Elysee
YouTube channel
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]